Abby everyone loved your apple pie bites
what else can you do with some graham
crackers Oh you mean other than s'mores
let's make my strawberry cheesecake
bites all right into my little blender
here a little cottage cheese and some
cream cheese a little squirt of Honey to
taste maybe a little more pop the lid on
let's get her smooth
throw a little dollop onto some graham
crackers just like Allah add some
strawberries and garnish with some
crushed almonds you got protein in the
cottage cheese fiber in the berries and
healthy fats in our almonds and listen
it's never going to replace the OG
cheesecake but for a quick snack you can
whip up in like five minutes it's pretty
damn good
thank you